[ Birds chirping ]
♪♪
-♪ Summer mornings
got me feeling pretty low ♪
♪ It's taking everything inside
me just to get up and go ♪
♪ Work is hard, life is tough ♪
♪ Sometimes
it feels like too much ♪
♪ All I wanna do
is stay in bed ♪
♪ Then I remember
something worth living for ♪
♪ I throw my covers off
and run out the door ♪
♪ 'Cause I might
meet a dog today ♪
♪ I might see a dog
and be like, "Hey" ♪
♪ When I pet the dog,
I'm gonna say... ♪
Excuse me, sir.
Are you a good boy?
[Baby voice]
Yes, you are!
You're a sweetie boy!
You're the king of the sweeties.
You're the lord
of all the sweeties!
-♪ Today's been super crazy,
I got hit by a bus ♪
♪ Paramedics came and told me
I was surely concussed ♪
♪ They tried to take me
to a hospital to check my head ♪
♪ I said, "No, please take me
to the dog park instead" ♪
♪ My friends and family
haven't seen me for days ♪
♪ 'Cause I've been sitting
at the dog park ♪
♪ Thinking about
all the ways that ♪
-♪ I might meet a dog today, I
might see a dog and be like... ♪
-Aah! Yay!
-Oh, my gosh. There's a dog.
-♪ When I pet the dog,
I'm gonna say ♪
-[Baby voice] You're a floofy
little poof, aren't you?!
You're the floofiest,
poofiest, joofiest...
[ Speaking gibberish ]
-♪ You can meet a dog
almost anywhere ♪
♪ It could be at a cookout
or a Renaissance fair ♪
♪ You could meet a Husky
on a walk in the woods ♪
♪ Or find a Bichon
by the B-balls ♪
♪ At a Dick's Sporting Goods ♪
♪ You could wait outside
a groomer and hide by a tree ♪
♪ And when you see
the perfect dog ♪
♪ You can jump out and scream ♪
♪ Then while the owner
is distracted ♪
♪ Your best friend will appear ♪
♪ Grab the dog and run away
when the coast is clear ♪
♪ Now you're holding
a Chihuahua ♪
♪ Running fast as you can ♪
♪ Then suddenly you realize that
you didn't make a good plan ♪
-Whoa, dude. I just stole a dog.
-Yeah, wait.
Why did you do that?
-I have no idea.
I got to return this dog.
I think I'm making
bad decisions.
I got hit by a bus this morning.
-What?! Like a bus, bus?
-Yes, like a bus, bus.
-Oh, my God.
Did you go to the hospital?
-No. I went to the dog park.
-Oh. Cool.
I would have done the same.
-♪ I might meet a dog today ♪
♪ I might see a dog and scream ♪
-[ Siren wails ]
-Run! Get outta here!
-Oh [bleep]! Run! Run!
-Just leave the dog!
Leave the dog! Leave it!